hopefully we'll finally understand the
source of our misery is government and
that the solution is free markets i am
nick gillespie with reasontv we're in
Las Vegas have freedom fest and we're
talking to Peter Schiff radio show host
and author most recently of how the
economy grows and Wyatt crashes very
quickly tell us why has our economy
crashed and it has not been able to pick
itself back up well it's actually in the
process of crashing and the real words
if it started here are we here or no
we're still unfortunately we're still
closer to the top okay you know we're in
a depression in the United States but
the depression was interrupted by some
economic stimulus that actually made the
problems worse and so now as the
stimulus is wearing off the recession
depression is resuming with a vengeance
and it's because you know the government
is interfering with the correction of
your read my book how an economy grows
and why crashes it explains how
government policy from the Federal
Reserve of Fannie and Freddie how that
distorts the free market and creates
these bubbles that inevitably have to
bust and then the government instead of
allowing the market to correct the
damage comes in and creates even more
layout for us the the Republican portion
of the blame the kind of the policies
under bush and the Republican Congress
what were what was going on there and
then what's happened since we've had a
new regime take over both parties have
spent recklessly run up deficits
increased the size of government
increased the amount of taxation so both
parties have blood on their hands I mean
the Republicans have better rhetoric as
far as talking to talk but they don't
walk the walk and neither do the
Democrats that's why we need a real
change in the Republican Party maybe
that is beginning here with the Tea
Party movement but so far you know I
don't see enough real difference in the
Republicans so I think they're going to
do anything to alter the trajectory that
we're on this is where the tea party
comes in where they're obviously they
lean towards the Republicans but they've
been keeping an arm's length are they
strong enough to kind of cattle prod
John Boehner and company
into actually being serious I mean we'll
see I mean Republicans stood firm and
prevented the debt ceiling from being
raised that would be a step in the right
direction because that could really
force the necessary spending cuts that
we need right you know it would be
painful to cut spending by that degree
but not nearly as painful as it's going
to be if we don't with it what's the
degree that ways that we have to go to
what what's the spending level we should
be adverse all at a minimum we shouldn't
spend more than we collected taxes which
means we have to cut about a one and a
half trillion dollars out of this year's
budget bro not over 10 years in one year
and that is massive to see right now the
government is borrowing 40 cents out of
every dollar it spends it can't do that
what is the likelihood that something
will change before we actually hit rock
bottom is I mean are we like as a
country are we like AAA or something
where we've got to hit bottom I think so
I don't think the politicians have the
stomach for trying to avert the crisis
because the medicine to cure the problem
doesn't taste good and so they don't
want to swallow it while they're in
office so unfortunately we're going to
have a real crisis and that's coming in
the next few years if the voters
actually understood what needed to
happen would they be able to force
politicians hands or is our voters part
of the problem they are part of the
problem because voters want something
for nothing I mean that's the problem
with democracy i mean the founding
fathers knew this 250 years ago people
vote for something for nothing so
politicians get elected promising to
give things to people and so people want
stuff for nothing and that is the
problem if that's part of human nature
it really can't be solved really but how
do we minimize the distortions that go
into the economy that lead to a crisis
that then call for more distortions well
we did it for a while with a
constitution which limited the power of
government but over time you know
government broke free of the chains of
the constitution that's the way Thomas
Jefferson defined and so we need to
reimpose constitutional law and
restrictions on the government and
hopefully when we have this economic
crisis that's coming you know what we
had in 2008 I mean that was the warm-up
I mean the main event is coming and it's
going to be brutal it's going to be a
collapse of the dollar that sends prices
for consumer goods through the roof
interest rates through the roof massive
unemployment much worse than we have now
hopefully we'll finally understand the
source of our misery is government right
and that the solution is free markets is
capitalism that we don't have that that
when we did have that a long time ago
our economy thrived and we created a lot
of wealth which we have since dissipated
with all these redistributionist
socialist programs that have been
layered onto the economy and we need to
go back to what made us great not what
is bankrupting us speaking of programs
tell us the best way to listen to your
radio program I've got a brand new radio
show I do it two hours weekdays monday
through friday everybody can listen to
it live on the internet or delayed for
free you go to shift radio.com the live
show is ten a.m. to noon it's a call-in
show hopefully eventually it'll be on
more you know terrestrial radio stations
but for now the internet is the best way
to listen okay well Peter Schiff thank
you very much for talking to reason TV
I'm Nicholas
you